horizon forbidden west the highly
anticipated sequel to horizon zero dawn
has officially been released and since i
just recently beat the game i wanted to
put together a story explained video for
you all as forbidden west has this weird
tendency to not only withhold
information from eloy and the player but
also just outright lies to them halfway
through the game which may make it a bit
difficult to understand the full story
as always spoiler warning ahead if you
haven't beaten forbidden west come back
later when you do with that out of the
way let's get started as always with
these types of videos i want to recap
the events of the previous game horizon
zero dawn and for whatever reason you
don't need a recap then you can skip
ahead using the chapters in the timeline
or just go to the time on screen to be
taken to the explanation of horizon
forbidden west so horizon zero dawn
takes place in a world with conflicting
technologies a world that has
self-functioning machines designed to
look like animals but all the humans in
the world wield bows and arrows that's
because horizon zero dawn actually takes
place in the year 3020 almost 1 000
years after the world had been destroyed
life on earth was much more advanced
than we are today the wealthiest man in
the world was ted farrow ceo of faro
automated solutions a company that
designed robots that acted as bodyguards
and personal servitors he earned a lot
of money from this company and expanded
his arsenal of robots to ones with
military applications however in 2064 a
glitch occurred in his line of robots
they weren't responding to the chain of
command and were acting on their own a
fix for this wasn't as simple as they
were all connected to a network together
and had zero back doors people could
enter meaning this not only affected
every robot ted farrow ever built but
there was no way to stop it another
problem arose as when the robots ran out
of fuel they would use nearby biomass as
a substitute meaning after time they
would drain the world of all organic
resources this was all irreversible the
extinction of every species on the
planet was guaranteed ted then reached
out to an old colleague dr elizabeth
sobek to tell her the bad news and to
ask her to come up with a solution after
days of planning she and a few
high-ranking members in the government
came up with three ideas project zero
dawn operation enduring victory and the
odyssey operation enduring victory was a
lie spun by the government that was
broadcasted to the entire planet telling
the people of the world to take up arms
against the pharaoh robots and defeat
them before they wipe us out everyone
who do of the plan knew this would fail
the operation wasn't to actually destroy
the robots but to buy time so project
zero dawn could be created project zero
dawn and the odyssey were the only two
ways the world could be saved the
odyssey was a colony ship and to have
surviving members live in space is a
temporary solution except that ship's
anti-matter engine malfunctioned causing
it to explode this meant that project
zero dawn was the only hope and the
person behind that only hope was gaia
gaia is a one-of-a-kind ai with nine
different functions and was designed to
create the earth when life was lost i'll
spare a lot of the details as most
aren't too important but majority of
these functions are things you would
expect like artemis and demeter which
was created to reintroduce fauna and
floral species back into the world using
preserved genetic stock however the
important ones are apollo hades minerva
hephaestus and elutia apollo was
supposed to be the hive mind of all the
collective data throughout human history
so our species didn't have to start at
square one this was intended to
collaborate with the other function
illuvia which was designed to
reintroduce human species back into the
world via cloning and then raising the
humans in places called cradle
facilities however ted farrow destroyed
apollo as he claimed it was the poison
that killed us in the first place
minerva was created to deactivate the
feral robots the deactivation code for
these robots wouldn't be created for at
least another 100 years which is long
after all humans would be dead so this
was meant for gaia to use so she could
start reintroducing the other functions
like deminer and artemis that we spoke
of hephaestus was the function dedicated
to the creation of the machines we see
in game originally all of these machines
were docile they were just doing
whatever they were designed to like
grazing or terraforming and finally
hades was essentially gaia's reset
button just in case she made life on
earth worse than before hades would
activate and eliminate everything she
did so she could start over again one
thing to remember is that at least
originally these functions were sort of
like buttons gaia could press except 19
years ago something else happened a
mysterious signal appeared this somehow
affected her functions and turned them
into separate ai so now they were just
like the pharaoh robots things that used
to be under the control of a creator but
are now their own entity the problem of
course was that these new ai only knew
how to do their task and since haiti's
function was to wipe the planet of life
he did what he knew and tried to take
control of gaia to make matters worse
hephaestus noticed that humans of the
world were killing the machines he made
and scrapping them for parts he saw this
as an attack which is why the machines
are now suddenly hostile in response to
this gaia overloaded the reactor at her
control site to gaia prime in an attempt
to take hades with her but also created
a backup plan she created a human using
the cradle facilities with an almost
exact copy of dr sobek's dna so she
could have access to these facilities
and be able to view the message that
we're seeing on screen this would then
let the person know what happened and
how they can stop it of course that
person being aloy as eloy was getting
older and progressing through her life a
man named silence someone who was
obsessed with the secrets of the old
world would come across this focused
device after repairing it he would
discover a signal which led him straight
to hades hades and silence would then
meet and they traded knowledge for power
hades wanted to wipe the world of life
as he was designed to so if that meant
giving away some knowledge he had to
some old obsessed man he would do it
this is what led hades to having a cult
back his wishes they believed they were
serving a god but they were just merely
his puppets i know i'm about to skip
quite a bit of the game but this recap
is already long as it is eventually eloy
would then meet with silence and also
come to understand who she is what
happened to the old world who hades is
and how to destroy him which we already
talked about hades intends to retake the
spire located near meridian and reawaken
the robot so he could destroy the world
again but through careful planning and
lots of killing ailoy and the people of
meridian survive and defeat hades she
activates the master override key that
she found earlier which purges the
extinction protocol and stops the swarm
of robots from attacking the world after
this the credits roll up and not before
two cutscenes play out one is eloy
listening to dr sobek's journal entries
and then finding her final resting spot
at her own home which is kind of a
touching scene considering that dr sobek
is technically her mom and then the
final cut scene is hades reawakening
again but being dragged into this device
held by silence claiming that they still
have more to discuss this is the end of
horizon zero dawn which leaves us with a
few questions what is silence doing with
hades and what caused that signal 19
years ago however with this now finally
finished we can now talk about horizon
forbidden west so forbidden west takes
place moments after zero dawn finished
as we hear from both aaron and varl that
eloy just left after the battle of hades
which not only makes them annoyed
because they wanted their dear friend to
join them but also because the party
they hosted was for her considering
she's the savior of meridian the reason
she left is that there is a new threat
coming to earth a plague of sorts named
the blight has been killing off plant
and animal life all around the world
furthermore any land affected by the
blood does inhabitable as we can see
aloy takes damage when walking over it
eloy now knowing what her true purpose
is in life she realizes she is the only
person in the world that can save the
earth eloy believes the solution to this
problem is gaia but since gaia destroyed
herself in the previous game she needs
to find a backup of her she has been
traveling for six months to try and find
one but she has been unsuccessful as
tedefaro deleted all the backups of gaia
her last lead is the facility that we go
through in the intro varl also shows up
and accompanies alloy in this endeavor
this facility ended up belonging to
farzenith they're an organization that
existed before the fall of humanity and
their ultimate goal was to explore the
stars this is why they built the odyssey
originally it was just going to be a
giant space station that was going to
transport people to another planet so
they could start new life on a new
colony and while this is still the
intended function the extinction sort of
accelerated the process however they
couldn't just build the odyssey and then
take off to a new colony so they went
into a trade agreement with zero dawn
they would provide some of their homer
archive 500 ectogenic chambers and five
ectogenesis research reports but in
return they would receive an alpha build
of the apollo database it won't be fully
complete but it's an almost complete
copy of all the human knowledge in
existence this seemed like a fair trade
except far zenith had more malicious
intentions they planned to take gaia so
they could use it on their new colony
the planet they landed on could be
inhabitable or extremely dangerous so by
using gaia they could shape any planet
into a new earth but zero dawn would
never let gaia leave their hands so far
zenith planned to send a spy into the
group and have them send a copy of gaia
over to them it seems that far zenith
was successful in their attempts to get
guy from zero dawn except both elizabeth
and another person named travis who was
the one who created the hades function
knew something like this would happen
thus they created a fake guy that didn't
even house gaia or her functions at all
it was also intended to destroy and
corrupt farzine's own data so far zenith
never ended up getting gaia but they did
however still get the apollo database as
an audio log further in the game shows a
conversation between a tilda and
elizabeth tilda tries to explain to her
what happened was something she was
unaware of and was someone simply acting
as a soul party furthermore she goes on
to explain that she punished the person
who is responsible for this and then
explains that it's not worth holding
this grudge between them when the world
is at stake so she reluctantly gave
tilde the copy of apollo anyway as we
know though ted destroyed apollo but
since this was a copy and one he was
possibly unaware of this would explain
why they still have it on the odyssey
all of this is great and all but it
amounts to nothing as in horizon zero
dawn we find a report that the odyssey
exploded but this is a lie and something
we'll get back to eloy now with no leads
and zero backups of gaia has to return
to the one person she hates the most
silence to find silence alien needs to
talk to spymaster murad back at meridian
but when visiting meridian again maraud
tells her about the glowing light that
spurted out of the ball he is
referencing the ending cutscene of zero
dawn we already know what happened but
as ayla climbs the spire she discovered
that silence intended for ailoy to use
his land so that he could then trap
hades later after the battle was
finished silence since the first game
has always been trying to discover the
secrets of the old world so we plan to
recapture hades in this device and then
interrogate him for information since
the spire was activated it pinged a
location for ayloid to follow him which
is in the forbidden west the forbidden
west is run by a large savage tribe
known as the tanakh they aren't
important to the overall story or even
really the immediate story right now so
we'll continue past our interaction with
them at the embassy but for context the
tanakh are made up of three tribes all
under one chief but a rogue version of
the tanakh just called the rebels in the
game attempts to usurp the throne and
appoint their new leader regala as the
actual chief upon arriving to the
coordinates given by silence we
discovered that he was successful in
interrogating hades silence found that
specific forms of data produce different
effects in hades the most efficient one
being a video of bunnies hopping through
a field of flowers which seemed to
agitate him the most after 10 days of
interrogation silence discovered what is
actually going on something we don't
even learn until the final minutes of
the game regardless this torture was
actually killing hades as it was
disintegrating his mind when we do find
hades we can see that there really isn't
much left of him he can barely talk and
most of the data he once knew was gone
as silence took it for himself the only
info we can squeeze out of him is that
the mysterious signal was sent by
someone called the masters and when the
signal was launched all the functions
who were now ai were scrambling to find
a suitable living space so they could
continue their operations once the
conversation is over with we delete
hades for good and then meet with
silence who says that the backup of gaia
we are looking for could be inside this
nearby facility it's in here where we
can discover that conversation we talked
about earlier between elizabeth and
tilda as well as travis talking to
elizabeth about their plans to create
the fake gaia we found earlier we also
discovered that travis found out who the
trader was and was able to get security
to take care of him when we reached the
core of the facility we find some
equipment that housed multiple versions
of hades and gaia thankfully all the
hades versions were destroyed and even
better we found two backups of gaia
sadly though the backups are pretty much
useless as they don't come with any of
the subordinate functions installed but
that doesn't mean we still can't find
them like i said earlier hades explained
that each of these functions went to
specific places so we can use gai to
help find the ai and then we can merge
them together bringing her back to full
power which is exactly what we do later
in the game however before this happens
as we're about to leave we hear the
loudspeaker deny entry from someone
outside meaning somebody is trying to
enter the facility we discovered that
these people are not only way more
advanced than anyone we've ever seen in
the game but they also have their own
clone of elizabeth sobeck called beta
these people are far zenith this is
where the game tends to go off the rails
with its story as either details are
told incorrectly but then corrected
later or not explained until the end of
the game so for now i'll be going out of
order but it will make the explanation a
lot easier so yes these people are from
far zenith who will now from this point
on be known as zeniths see the odyssey
being blown up is what they wanted us to
believe the odyssey never blew up and it
was successful in its launch across the
galaxy farzinith made it seem like they
failed that no one bothered to check up
on them allowing the group to be
completely isolated their journey took
them 8.6 light years away to a planet
within the serious star system it was
during this time that they evolved
exponentially the zeniths are able to
fly have hand cannons that chew plasma
energy and are equipped with a shield
that makes them impenetrable to damage
at least when it comes to primitive
weapons like bows and arrows however we
learn from beta that these are the same
people who left on the odyssey as
opposed to ailoy and all the other
people on earth who have the zero dawn
people as their ancestors the zeniths
don't the same ones who left the earth a
thousand years ago when the earth fell
to the pharaoh robots are the same ones
who are still alive today meaning they
are immortal so while life on earth was
busy playing ketchup the zeniths were
creating new breakthroughs and all sorts
of technologies but history is bound to
repeat itself and it did just that while
the zeniths were on their new planet so
they attempted to see how far the line
in the sand could go immortality in the
physical realm is great but what about
digitally can you live on digitally
forever was the question they asked this
was the next step in their experiments
but it came at a cost as with anything
in life things are bound to fail and
many of the zenith experiments in this
digital immortality failed the
experiment was ultimately deemed a full
complete failure but it was never shut
down they kept all the failed minds they
couldn't successfully copy and because
it was just laying dormant without
supervision it was able to gain
sentience and break containment this new
amalgamation of failed minds wiped the
zenith homeworld in just a couple of
hours it's unclear how this technology
really works but i believe that these
failed copies of the zenith mind were
more active than just data on a screen
it was literally the mind of another
person just not as complete so it
probably had some sort of sentience or
consciousness with it and when all these
failed copies discover that the zenith
left them to rot in containment it
formed this new being called nemesis
this is what broke containment and
killed off almost all the zenith
inhabiting the planet this nemesis was
also the cause of the mysterious signal
that destroyed gaia causing all the
functions to become a.i when the zenith
discovered that they were dying out they
took to the stars again and came back to
earth but nemesis due to having their
minds of their own people who used to
work at farzenith and thus living on
earth figured that's where they were
obviously going next so in anticipation
for this it sent that signal to prevent
the zenith from living safely on earth
this explains why we find documents at
their base talking about launch
trajectories and reports as they plan to
leave earth and go to some random star
in a random galaxy so far away that not
even nemesis could find them that's why
the zeniths want gaia because with her
help they could rebuild a new world on a
completely different planet they believe
the earth is finished because the thing
they created wants to deny them a safe
place to live back on earth and
obviously it makes sense why the zenith
would come back to earth and why nemesis
would attempt to destroy the earth
because it's their old home there's no
need to discover new planets and find
out if it's inhabitable or not when they
have a home that they can go back to of
course the zenith more than likely also
assume zero dawn works so they could
just then go back to earth and rebuild
that's why nemesis sent the signal but
since it didn't work as intended nemesis
is now coming to earth to destroy the
planet itself this is why the zenith
needed gaia but as we know many of the
facilities here are locked down due to
an identiscanned feature so they ended
up creating a copy of elizabeth sobek
named beta so they could access these
forbidden areas it's never explained how
they managed to get a copy of
elizabeth's dna on the odyssey but i
assume that they copied it from zero
dawn when they were infiltrating it to
take gaia regardless this is the full
complete story of the zeniths and how
they arrived on earth so now that we're
caught up we can go back to the game
before being attacked by the zenith we
found the location of the function
minerva and when ailoy escapes the
zenith she heads in its location in
hopes of merging her and gaia together
after merging the two gaia is once again
created eloy then asks her what the
other functions are and she gets a few
answers aether demeter and poseidon are
located nearby functions apollo artemis
and elutia are gone and fs this is a bit
of a weird case which i'll get into in a
moment remember apollo was the archive
of all the human data artemis
reintroduced animal life back on earth
and elutia was made to create humans
again from those genetic stocks they
kept away the gaia explains that they're
gone but it's because the zeniths have
them she doesn't know this and it's not
figured out until later but we do know
that they do indeed have them but they
don't have a gaia kernel to merge them
with that kernel is the device we place
the ai in when we capture them this is
odd however because we saw them take one
but later when we get a distress call
from beta we see that she locked herself
inside the container with the kernel
they took earlier as for the other
functions aether was made to detoxify
the earth's atmosphere while poseidon
was made to detoxify the water on earth
and demeter introduced floral species
back into the earth as well with these
we can actually combat most of the
problems on earth like the blight and
the raging wind storms but only for a
few months we need the final function
hephaestus to truly get things back in
working order the reason how fast this
is so special is that since the signal
he was the only one to actually evolve
he isn't like the other functions who
stayed in one location he has grown his
influence across all the cauldrons where
he produces the machines meaning he
isn't stuck to one specific place so
that was quite a bit of info so let me
recap the stakes here currently hades is
gone and hephaestus isn't captured since
he's the hardest to find among the other
seven minerva is held by gaia with
aether demeter and poseidon following
later as we progress through the game
while the other three artemis apollo and
aluthia are under zenith control but
since they don't have that gaia kernel
we discussed anymore thanks to beta they
can't really do much with them hopefully
that makes things a bit easier to
understand so now eloy sets out to find
aether demeter and poseidon these
missions aren't too important with the
only relevant detail being that alloy is
successful in finding all three ai and
merging them however i still want to
discuss them a bit to get either we need
to assist the tanakh as the chief wants
to start the arena up again but not only
is one of the clans within the tribe not
sending participants ragala the leader
of the rebels also plans to attack
during this time we also discover that
the true origin of the tanakh is based
on the ten a group of people who they
worship which just happens to be the us
army after finding aether our task would
then be to get to poseidon except guy
intercepted a distress signal coming
from elutia as we already talked about
though the distress signal was actually
from beta who we rescue and bring back
to the base but during this time we find
some rebel tribes into fighting a zenith
and they actually managed to kill her
apparently that weapon was able to break
her shield and leave her vulnerable this
is because the one who's been working
with them and not just creating this
weapon but also teaching them how to
ride machines was silence he has his own
agenda like usual but we'll discuss that
later when it's relevant getting back to
the ai we find poseidon in the ruins of
las vegas where we meet some performers
who have been trying to scavenge the
area for these things called embers once
we get poseidon the lights turn back on
and we can see what las vegas looks like
and it's pretty gorgeous the trio
planned to make this a suitable place
for people to come for things like food
shelter and of course entertainment so
they're pretty much remaking las vegas
out of the ruins of las vegas
fantastic as for demeter its location is
guarded by a group called the quen
they're here because of a belief they
call the legacy which requires them to
research and discover all the ancient
tombs and ruins of the old world a tier
where we meet alva a diviner amongst the
queen who claims that the ancestors left
the focus devices to them and them only
alva is here so that she can find info
on how to stop her people from starving
and their crops from dying this means
her homeland is being ravaged by the
blight so now we have a common goal we
then work with her to uncover the
secrets of the facility and eventually
find demeter eloy then takes demeter and
alva takes some of the files back to her
homeland so that she can come back with
knowledge on how to stop their crisis
from getting worse once we return gaia
sets up a plan to capture hephaestus
which is to contain him in a location
with a physical connection to gaia and a
place that has two data cores a cauldron
called gemini she plans to get
transplanted into one core then attract
if festus to her location then trap him
in the other course the two can merge
however not only will we need to
physically carry gaia to gemini the
zenith will be able to detect us once we
start the merge and to prevent us from
getting inside hephaestus also removed
the alpha level clearance security from
it all seems lost except we remember
that ted farrow has omega level
clearance which is one above alpha
meaning we can get inside as long as we
have his clearance code to get this
though we need to find thebes his
private bunker he stayed in when the
world ended if you recall from horizon
zero dawn the staff didn't just wait for
death to take them they all hid in
elysium which was a bunker capable of
housing a couple thousand people however
people who were either the creator of
the project or were the leaders of the
specific functions like elizabeth and
travis didn't make it to elysium in time
so they went to their own bunker at gaia
prime well just like them ted farro
being the egotistical man he is wanted
his own unique bunker called thebes no
one knows where thebes is though except
the only people who may have a chance of
knowing is the quen so we travel even
further west to meet alva and her people
is here where we're introduced to
overseer bohai and the leader of the
expedition seo whose name is more than
likely a misinterpretation of ceo ceo
believes that ted was the savior of the
world and that elizabeth it was merely
his assistant which couldn't be farther
from the truth ceo shows us where thebus
is located in hopes that we can get him
inside however ted programmed the door
to only open with his dna so aloy won't
even work this time so we have to sneak
in the back way according to some of the
notes we can uncover that ted was living
here with a few other people but the
most important one of all was dr samtao
who apparently worked with him so he
could basically achieve immortality we
can read up on some of the logs and see
that according to dr samtao his cells
were replenishing faster than ever
before but he just needed more time for
the mutations to settle down tedefaro is
indeed alive and immortal but he isn't a
human he's most likely a mutated beast
that is just sitting there in pain for
life while we sadly don't get to see
what his final form looks like i think
it's a fitting punishment for someone
like him ceo sees him and commands his
soldiers to burn the place down and to
kill aeloy and alva so there are no
witnesses this causes the reactor to go
off and causes the bunker to collapse as
well aloy then grabs the omega level
clearance and escapes with her and alva
being the only survivors with everything
all set to go the team heads to gemini
to start the merging process hephaestus
manages to break free momentarily until
alloy forces him back into the core we
have now hit the last act of the game
and it's during this point that
everything seems to be going smoothly
until the zeniths arrive in the middle
of the merge elo is knocked down varl is
killed and beta is taken but before they
leave tilda activates a sort of
flashbang and is able to stun the other
two zeniths while giving her time to
rescue aeloy before taking the fight to
hephaestus we end up talking with beta
and we find out that while the zenith
were putting her to work and basically
making her her slave one of them that
being tilda was actually quite nice to
her during her break she would send her
to this private channel of there so that
they could relax and talk together it's
clear from this that tilden never liked
her people but what really convinced her
to join us was actually alloy she
discovered eloy's focus the one that she
destroyed when talking to silence around
the first time we meet the zeniths and
upon repairing it she discovered how
powerful ailoy really is she was amazed
at how much he had accomplished in 20
years when tilde couldn't even do that
in a thousand she now realizes that far
zenith was wrong and now she wants to
help the people of earth this isn't
entirely true as once again nemesis is
coming and they also plan to leave earth
at some point so tilda is partially
lying here she does care about aeloy and
we'll get to that later but she really
doesn't care about the earth however her
other plan is a lot more legit as she
plans to take down the other zeniths
ragala and her rebels led by silence
plan to assault the zenith base here in
the forbidden west many of them will die
but silence doesn't really care is all
he wants to do is use his new weapon to
deactivate their shields kill them then
take the apollo database for himself for
silence a man who is obsessed with old
world knowledge the apollo database is
like heaven to him which is why he wants
it while silence attacks the base we're
going to sneak in through a back exit so
we can get the jump on the other zeniths
however both silence and tilda's plan do
not sit right with alloy so she comes up
with her own illog plans to override a
sun wing grab a canister from inside one
of the ancient metal devils and then
drop that on the regal's army of
machines all of the machines are
destroyed to which alloy takes the
opportunity to challenge regala to a
fight ailoy wins and you can ultimately
decide her fate here i decided to keep
her as we're going to need as many
people as possible for this upcoming
siege the reason she did this in the
first place was that these people didn't
waste their lives fighting an enemy they
clearly can't kill she then gets a
message from silence about what she just
did but she ends up forcing him to come
to the base and meet her there so aaron
zou tilda alva cotalo silence and regala
assuming you let her live are all at the
base together and going over the plan
tilda will lead them to the back of the
entrance of the zenith base the group
will face overwhelming resistance from
the zenith so they plan to use silen's
new weapon to take down their shields
all while beta activates the fabricator
at the base causing it to create a ton
of machines to fight the specters that
will accompany the zeniths while this is
happening aloy in secret wants kotalo
and ava to go to the base's regulator
and destroy it so they can stop the
drones after which she wants them to
infiltrate the zenith network so they
can find more info on them more
specifically what tilda is hiding this
part of the plan leads to the discovery
we talked about earlier regarding
nemesis and the zenith homeworld the
group then makes it to the base before
being caught by the zenith until silence
activates his weapon which lowers their
shield leading to them being torn apart
by the machines they all split off
trying to defeat the drones while ailoy
until the deal with eric and gerrard and
while it is a tough fight aeloy defeats
eric and rescues beta while tilda takes
care of gerrard this then leads into the
conversation about nemesis with tilda
she also mentions that one of her
biggest regrets was letting elizabeth
stay on earth to die while she prospered
on the odyssey so she wants to make it
right by having aeloy accompany her on
their new planet eloy of course refuses
and the two fight ailoy kills tilde
marking the end of the zenith on earth
but obviously she isn't done yet nemesis
is coming to earth and we need to find
out how to stop it as the camera pans
away from the destroyed base we reach
the end of horizon forbidden west one
threat is gone but another has awoken so
the question is what now well i think
forbidden west will have a dlc but
probably not about nemesis the dlc could
end up with the group finding a weapon
to possibly fight it but i can see a dlc
wrapping up this whole story you might
be scratching your head thinking how
eloy and company are going to fight the
nemesis when even the zenith couldn't
put up a fight but as tilda explains it
was the collective mind of all the
zeniths meaning it knew all the planets
access code system specs and other
security protocols so it was able to use
that to its advantage nemesis won't have
that on earth it may have some of the
knowledge of the buildings on earth so
that could be a problem but it wouldn't
wipe everything that fast while that
happens it seems that the group splits
off to spread the word about the
impending doom in hopes of recruiting
people to their cause eloy already has
many allies like the nora and meridian
but aaron is the leader of the vanguard
alva can get the quen to back her kotalo
and chief akaro can also back her with
the three tribes and zo was affiliated
with the utaru hell even silence was
originally going to take the apollo
database and the ship off planet but
decides to go against what he said and
stays anyway they have a lot of people
that could rally behind their cause
which could prove troublesome for
nemesis this leads me to believe that
we'll most likely be getting another
game and the horizon franchise dedicated
to the fight against nemesis and i think
after that will this game finally come
to a close with the horizon franchise
finished i really don't know what they
could do past the nemesis fight as i
said before a dlc does seem likely but
it's unclear what it will be about it
might just be another group aloe wants
to recruit for the nemesis fight or
maybe it'll be something else so who
knows both horizon forbidden west
finally finished we come to the end of
the video let me know how you like the
video in the comments down below and
also be sure to tell me your thoughts on
the story as a whole i know sci-fi media
does get some flack for going a bit too
sci-fi in certain parts and while i do
think the zeniths do stretch that
sometimes overall i didn't mind it as
always like the video if you enjoyed and
subscribe if you're new feel free to
share it with someone if you want as
well of course thank you to my returning
viewers for coming back to another video
and with that take care everyone
goodbye
[Music]
you